alors si ce divorce est aussi commenté
c'est parce qu'il s'agit d'une situation
inédite on l'a entendu c'est aussi parce
que le couple présidentiel a mêler le
public et le privé Nicolas Sarkozi a
toujours affiché le rôle de premier plan
joué par Cécilia dans sa vie personnelle
et politique jusqu'à ces derniers mois
récit signé Michell d'ond Jean-Marc nnou
elle ne voulait pas venir à la Concorde
d'ailleurs elle reste en arrière et
Michel Alarie unit leurs
mains
6 mai 2007 jour de victoire pour Nicolas
Sarkozi en coulisse une journée
difficile pour son couple plus tard on
apprendra même que la future première
dame n'a pas
voté il est il est bien loin le temps o
CIA SAR faisait visiter au caméras ses
appartements privés du ministère de
l'Intérieur les SAR se voi comme les
Kennedy une famille politique moderne il
m le bonheurcère au service d'unjet
présidentiel vie priv vie publique les
Sarkozi effacent la frontière sous l'œil
des médias lorsque son mari prend la
tête de l'UMP Cecilia Sarkozi devient
chef de cabinet du parti entre les deux
les relations se tendent et en pleine
campagne pour le référendum de 2005 elle
craque voici la dernière réunion de
l'UMP à laquelle assiste Cécilia Sarkozi
la tension est presque palpable en bout
de table se trouve le publicitaire
Richard ATA avec lequel elle passera
plusieurs mois à New York la crise
conjugale de Nicolas Sarkozi défrait la
chronique il fait face à la télévision
alors la vérité elle est très simple
comme des millions de familles la mienne
a connu des difficultés ces difficultés
nous sommes en train de les surmonter
est-ce que je dois en dire plus je ne le
pense pas Cécilia compte beaucoup pour
moi chacun le sait je crois que la
réciproque est également vrai la
séparation dure presque 1 an été 2006 il
se retrouve et le ministre de
l'Intérieur affiche la réconciliation
lors d'un voyage en Guyane on parle
désormais de pipolisation de la vie
politique mais Nicolas Sarkozi affirme
pourtant qu'il ne veut plus exposer sa
vie familiale c'est justement instruit
de l'expérience que j'ai décidé plus
jamais durant toute la campagne
présidentielle Cécilia Sarkozi reste en
retrait et son absence est omniprésente
mais elle s'interroge entre l'ombre et
la lumière qu'elle vit choisir le 16 mai
2007 dans la cour de l'Élysée elle
rayonne à la tête de sa famille
recomposée et donne le ton d'une air
nouvelle à
l'Élysée tu le connais lui
c'est le modèle réuit du le couple
présidentiel donne alors l'apparence
d'une relation
[Musique]
apaisée ça
j'adore mais si les gestes amoureux sont
bien là le cœur n'y est pas pour Cécilia
Sarkozi commence pour elle une vie entre
convenance et protocole pour sa première
apparition au G8 elle casse les codes du
club des dirigeants de la planète en
séchant la photo des femmes de chez chef
d'État tout le monde s'interroge sur
l'idée qu'elle se fait de son rôle
elle veut prendre son temps
protéger sa famille je moi je trouve que
c'est très bien la façon dont elle le
fait Nicolas sarzi reconnaît les affres
de son épouse et pour son premier 14
juillet il lui adresse un message public
je voudrais dire à céilia et à Judi mais
elles sont très belles toutes les deux
sur le Peron de l'Élysée quelques jours
plus tard céilia Sarkozi devient une
héroïne nationale en Bulgarie elle
ramène dans leur patrie les infirmières
prisonnières en Libye depuis 8 ans
émissaire personnel du président elle
s'est beaucoup impliqué dans cette
affaire une grande
joieneur de pouir les ramener à la
Bulgarie désormais l'agenda
international masque ou accompagne les
crises en vacances aux États-Unis elle
prétexte une engine de dernière minute
pour se décommander au piqueenic offert
par la famille buou céilia Sarkozi ne
veut plus de cette vie dans le monde
politique aux obsèques de Jacques Martin
le père de ses deux fille sa décision
est prise et elle annule dans la foulée
sa présence à New York elle n'assistera
pas au premier discours de son mari à la
tribune de
l'ONU alors que Nicolas Sarkozi se rend
seul en Bulgarie auprès des infirmières
les rumeurs de séparation se font de
plus en plus précises SIG des temps
l'Élysée vient d'officialiser pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de la
République une rupture conjugale au
sommet de
l'État on est dans la PR